шановні журналісти шановні
українці доросла Політика - це перш за
все відповідальність а невід'ємною
частиною відповідальності є підзвітність
і можливость звітувати виборцям які вас
делегували до
парламенту хочу нагадати що європейська
Солідарність
єдина фракція яка звітує вже роки ми
були єдині хто
звітував про чотирьохрічну роботу за
підсумками
2019-2023 років
коли Верховна рада України працювала вже
4чотири роки і сьогодні ми єдина фракція
яка звітує про свою діяльність за 2023
рік сьогодні для України є одна
об'єднуюча мета це перемога у ві за наше
майбутнє і формула української Перемоги
це армія мова Віра ЄС і
НАТО складові цієї формули - це
ефективне використання наших українських
можливостей здобуття міжнародної
підтримки на нашому шляху до ЄС і
НАТО підтримка Українського війська
відповідність критеріям членства в ЄС і
НАТО але також це і розвиток української
економіки захист українського
гуманітарного
простору і саме тому наші пріоритети
це перш за все підтримка українського
воїна підтримка української армії
підтримка збройних сил
України європейська та євроатлантична
інтеграція міжнародна дія ність і робота
в міжнародних
делегаціях це економічна безпека нашої
держави це підтримка української мови
української культури захист нашої
віри нам як єдині реальнонії опозиції
заважали нам блокували наші
ініціативи крали наші законопроекти не
випускали нашого лідера та народних
депутатів нашої фракції на важливі
міжнародні зустрічі по захисту
України за кордоном Але тим не менше Не
дивлячись на це європейська Солідарність
працювала значно ефективніше в 23му році
також у порівнянні з будь-якою іншою
фракцією чи групою парламента бо наші
ключові функції бути парламентським
спецназом щоб не не допустити згортання
реформ захистити реформи і впроваджувати
подальші реформи ми будемо робити Не
дивлячись на спротив
і блокування з боку
влади колеги А як сказав Артур дійсно
одні з головних пріоритетів для нашої
роботи протягом і всіх попередніх років
протягом 23-го року були наше наближення
до Європейського Союзу і до
північно-атлантичного Альянсу тому
європейська Солідарність абсолютно
послідовно Протягом цього року включно
виступала за виконання усіх повноцінне
виконання усіх семи умов які
супроводжували рішення про надання нам
кандидатського статусу для того щоби
якомога швидше перейти до рішення про
відкриття перемовин про членство України
А ми реєстрували свої ініціативи ми
працювали над тим щоби вичистити
псевдоініціативи під красивими гаслами
наших колег Ми попереджали коли колеги з
більшості
робили ну абсолютно неприпустимі кроки
по реєстрації законопроектів нібито на
виконання цих умов а насправді
намагалися гратися в гру в наперстке
зокрема це стосувалося закону про відбір
суддів Конституційного Суду тоді коли на
жаль незважаючи на наші попередження
незважаючи на наші виступи на наші
ініціативи довелося переробляти
Верховній Раді повністю ухвалений
законопроект який був ухвалений спочатку
В 21му році в кінці 21-го року Ой
вибачте 22-го року а довелося
переробляти його після звіту
Європейської комісії якщо не чують нас
добре що поки що продовжують чути
партнерів Також ми пишаємося тим що Нам
вдалося забезпечити виконання однієї з
умов стосовно захисту прав національних
меншин і спільнот в Україні саме в такий
спосіб який гарантував би
також Захист української ідентичності
української мови Я думаю колеги про Це
скажуть більше зокрема ми
також про понували ми підтримали всі
абсолютно антикорупційні ініціативи і
раді що нарешті ми повернулися до тих
реформ які ми здійснювали в
24-2019 роках зокрема повернулися до
електронного декларування Це теж те що
Ми попереджали що відміняти це
електронне декларування А немає
необхідності і немає
е ну Ми не маємо права це робити Через
те що це є засаднича умова того ж таки
безвізу Але разом з тим Ми також
пропонували щоби до цього електронного
декларування також були залучені всі там
позаштатні радники офісу президента які
виконують де-факто функції управлінські
але не несуть за це ніякої
відповідальності і не мають жодної
підзвітності і ми будемо продовжувати це
робити ми вважаємо що вони абсолютно є
такими ж публічними особами і мають бути
підзвітними і прозорими для
суспільства ми очікуємо що зараз уряд на
основі тої звіту Європейської комісії
має нарешті вже два місяці пройшло як
звіт Європейської комісії був наданий
Україні 8
листопада має за нарешті затвердити план
заходів план дій на основі якого ми
можемо виконувати ці ці рекомендації
Європейської комісії а не робити це
знову в останній момент як студенти
перед іспитом як Верховна Рада
ухвалювала закони прямо під е під
оцінювання е ми наполягаємо і
звертаємося до уряду щоби цей план
нарешті був затверджений і цей план має
стати
е важливою складовою законодавчої роботи
Верховної Ради України на сьогодні ми не
бачимо такого плану законодавчих робіт
ми не бачимо навіть плану і порядку
денного на найближчі засідання Верховної
Ради України очевидно що такі речі не
можуть продовжуватися і це теж одна з
вимог Європейської комісії щоби
інституції набували своєї спроможності
чи відновлювали свої спроможності
зокрема щоби Верховна Рада України
відновила свою контролюючу функцію свою
функцію законодавчого органу який би та
також вимагав підзвітності від урядовців
мені би хотілося щоби ми це взяли всі на
озброєння і наші вимоги до проведення
тих же
ж годин запитань до уряду на яких ми
наполягаємо буквально що погоджувальної
ради підзвітності і висвітлення роботи
Верховної Ради України на
парламентському телеканалі рада який
перетворився на пропагандистський рупор
офісу президента щоби ці речі
повернулися до нормальності і ми
функціонували як реальна демократична
європейська країна яка націлена на
отримання членства в Європейському Союзі
А
ми наполягаємо на тому що Верховна Рада
України також має
пріоретизувати законодавчу роботу по
наближенню нас до членства в
північно-атлантичному альянсі вже два
місяці тому відбулося засідання
України засідання ради українанато на
якому було схвалено
партнерами нібито річну національну
оновлену узгоджену річну національну
програму Ми не бачили того щоби уряд
нарешті ухвалив її і оприлюднив для того
щоби ми могли використати той час який
ще маємо до саміту у Вашингтоні для того
щоб ми могли справді наполягати на
запрошення України до Альянсу а не
працювати в такому авральному режимі як
це відбувалося перед самітом у Вільнюсі
і На жаль ми не отримали тих рішень які
є настільки принципово важливими для
України ми далі Будемо продовжувати
ініціювати законопроекти і постанови
проекти постанов які стосуються
європейської євроатлантичної інтеграції
але і Далі будемо продовжувати
намагатися працювати на міжнародній
арені ми пишаємося Тим що саме
наші депутати і депутатки дуже ефектив
но відпрацювали цей рік в міжнародних
наших делегаціях парламентських
делегаціях парламентських делегаціях в
ОБСЄ в пар'є а в пачес в парламентському
комітеті асоціації а в парламентській
асамблеї НАТО
ми одночасно весь час Протягом цього
року стикалися з перешкоджанням нашій
діяльності на міжнародній арені
перешкоджанням діяльності як очільника
політичної нашої сили Петра Порошенка
так і нас як окремих народних депутатів
і і Ірина
Геращенко кілька разів не оддноразово
була позбавлена можливості участі як
офіційна
представниця нашої фракції в
парламентській асамблеї ОБСЄ Володимир
ар'єв був позбавлений такої можливості
участі як член офіційний від нашої
фракції в парламентській делегації
євронест мені Марі іонові Ірині Фріз
іншим
колегам На жаль постійно ставили палки в
колеса І ми бачимо що цей процес
продовжується ми буквально з
цими вчора побачили нове
розпорядження голови Верховної Ради
України
про порядок закордонних відряджень ми
розуміємо що це є розпорядження яке
спрямоване прямо безпосередньо проти
однієї політичної сили а саме фракції
європейської солідарності
на нашу думку це розпорядження воно ну
порушує засадничі засадничі речі
представництва народних
депутатів інтересів своїх виборців як
всередині країни так і на міжнародній
арені ми вважаємо що ці що це
розпорядження воно є перевищенням
службових
повноважень паном спікером і є на жаль
тим розпорядженням яке сьогодні буде
перешкоджати захисту національних
інтересів України в той час коли нам
потрібно посилити своє представництво на
міжнародній арені для того щоби не
тільки наростити допомогу Україні а вже
на даний момент зберегти ту допомогу
Україні яку ми маємо до цього е до цього
часу ми сподіваємося що нам вдасться
добитися спільно з іншими колегами
будемо закликати інших колег відміни
цього розпорядження і ми готуємо цілий
комплекс заходів для того щоби не дати
цим авторитарним тенденціям всередині
українського парламенту розвиватися далі
Ну і для нас важливо також
щоби ми продовжуючи продовжуючи нашу
роботу мали ту єдність яка для нас є
принципово важливою на міжнародному
фронті ця єдність може бути забезпечена
тільки взаємоповагою і неухильним
виконанням законів України на цьому
будемо концентруватися як контролюючи
виконуючи контролюючу функцію ну
опозиційної політичної сили
Ростислав шановні друзі європейську
Солідарність часто називають
парламентським спецназом Питання в тому
що нам доводиться різними
парламентськими методами у взаємодії з
громадянським суспільством у взаємодії з
експертами проводити іціювати інколи
примушувати більшість до прийняття тих
рішень які необхідні для країни
необхідні в першу чергу для оборони для
підтримки збройних сил для підтримки
всіх сил оборони рішень необхідних для
європейської євроатлантичної інтеграції
Тому що тільки вступ до НАТО і ЄС
забезпечить перемогу України і мир і в
Україні і навколо неї і крах остаточний
крах путінської імперії і і її задумів
це питання мови віри всього що робить
нас українцями і для того ми підтримуємо
і просуваємо ідеї щодо розвитку
українського гуманітарного простору це
питання економіки розвитку це питання
громад і їх захисту проти сваволі Отже
все ті питання Чим живе зараз Україна і
основні речі які ми пропонуємо якраз
стосуються найбільш нагальних питань
того щоб Україна могла себе захистити
щоб розвивалась її економіка щоби
українство могло поширюватися а руский
мир отримав свій логічний
кінець в цьому році доводилося діяти не
завдяки а всупереч як на жаль взагалі це
характерне для цього скликання
парламенту е коли е дуже сумнівною
настановою але які з 19-го року на жаль
сповідується владою А є спроба
ігнорувати європейську Солідарність і
тих мільйонів людей які нас
підтримують адже це не питання лише
політичної сили це не питання персоналії
але це питання представництва це Питання
підтримки мільйонів людей і це питання
реалізації того запиту на європейську
інтеграцію е на ее потужні збройні сили
на сильну Україну яка займе своє чільне
місце серед країн світу яке ми як
народні депутати Маємо виконати і тому в
цьому скликанні парламенту нам
доводиться дуже часто стикатися з тим що
наші законопроекти свідомо
ігноруються нам доводиться дуже часто
або миритися з тим що під іншою назвою і
іншою автурою проходять наші ідеї і тут
згадується Степан Бандера з тим що ми
перемагаємо якщо перемагають наші ідеї
дуже часто доводиться
миритися з тим але ми в такому разі
розуміємо що об'єднавшись представниками
інших фракцій маємо проводити ті основні
позиції від яких яких чекає від нас
суспільство ці питання насамперед
стосується
наприклад знаходження коштів для
фінансування армії спрямування туди
коштів які розподіляються або на інші
силові структури непропорційно великій
кількості або на так званий марафон який
уже давно віджив будь-яку свою роль
навіть якщо вона колись існувала і
кожного разу від бюджету до конкретних
законопроектів ми обстоюємо і вимагаємо
збільшення підтримки збройних сил
України ми
вимагаємо ухвалення законопроекту який
чітко дозволить головнокомандувачу
збройних сил України подавати президенту
України представлення на призначення і
звільнення командувачів
родів військ керівника Генерального
штабу для того щоби військові могли
спокійно працювати а політики не могли
Втручатися в їхню роботу і
дестабілізувати найважливішу на сьогодні
роботу збройних сил України ми вимагаємо
ухвалення закону щодо автоматичного
електронного визначення статусу учасника
бойових дій є дуже чіткий законопроект
який дає шість днів на те щоби людина
яка воює отримала всі
необхідні визначені законом переваги На
жаль поки що це питання не вирішується
це питання гуманітарної сфери це питання
в першу чергу остаточно поставити крапку
щодо до існування в країні Московської
церкви яка продовжує На жаль
отруювати суспільство Московської
пропагандою це питання гуманітарної
деколонізації для того щоби не лише в
назвах але і по суті в роботі органів
влади місцевого самоврядування в
культурі в мистецьких продуктах ми не
несли оцю печатку руского мира Яка ще
залишається
це питання безпеки в громадах це питання
бомбосховищ бо ми подавали законопроект
який чітко визначає яким чином має бути
забезпечено наявність укриттів і як вони
мають підтримуватися в належному стані
це питання збереження того природнього
зв'язку який склався між місцевими
громадами і бригадами і ми наполягаємо
щоби розширити з 10% до 30%
норму відрахування від податку на доходи
фізичних осіб які мають бути спрямовані
безпосередньо в бригади тому що бійці
командири знають краще що саме
закуповувати в якій кількості і яким
чином Ну і На жаль ми стикаємося з тим
що кадрові
законопроекти пропозиції щодо кадрових
рішень не підтримуються чинною владою
всупереч регламенту всупереч д яким
законом колеги вже говорили і ще скажуть
про абсолютно абсурдну ситуацію яка
виникає із ставленням до європейської
солідарності відтак до тих мільйонів
виборців які підтримують нашу позицію
Шановні колеги якщо трохи говорити про
цифри бо зараз модно апелювати до
екселівських табличок маємо сказати що
223 проекти законів постанов заяв або
безпосередньо депутатам європейської
солідарності або разом з іншим Бо як я
сказав практично завжди подати з кимось
іншим це збільшити шанс на проходження
акту нами представлено І до речі маю
сказати що
питома вага виходить
8,3 пропозиції на народного депутата що
ну суттєво більше того чи мо може
похвилитися моно більшість тому що вони
наприклад спромоглися на
5,2 законодавчих
пропозицій на свої цю величезну фракцію
яка і голосує лише за підтримки
забороненої опзж і деяких інших фракцій
груп і як бачимо не дуже активно себе
показує в законодавчій діяльності тож
підсумовуючи наша робота спрямована на
те щоби забезпечити підтримку Збройних
Сил України гарантувати європейську
євроатлантичну інтеграцію провести ті
реформи які необхідні і не допустити
відхо ходу відкату в реформах бо дуже
часто ми зараз бачимо і в заявах
закордонних колег і в закордонних медіа
констатацію того що по дуже багатьох
позиціях допущено відхід відкат від тих
завоювань які ми мали з 14го по 19-й рік
от недопущення цього робота в комітетах
робота в робочих групах боротьба за
кожну правку є основою нашої роботи в
парламентікономіка
Шановні колеги цей рік для економіки
взагалі був випробувальним і те що нам
допомога партнерів дозволила вистояти це
правда але перспективи самої України
залежали і наразі залежить від умов які
ми можемо створити для діяльності в
Україні умов для українського Бізнесу
для іноземного
інвестора і саме Від цього від цих
факторів буде залежати чи наші люди
будуть отримувати зарплату чи вони
зможуть залишатися працювати І жити в
Україні і отримувати всю весь спектр
послуг від
держави наші ініціативи протягом 2023
року якраз і були спрямовані на
спрощення а не ускладнення умов для
роботи в Україні на зниження а не
підвищення тиску на інвестора для
прозорості і простоти роботи а не схем і
сво лі перевіряючих органів на
конкурентні умови а не доступ окремих
груп до бюджетних грошей і насправді
Якщо говорити про кількість поданих
проектів закону в плані в щодо
стосується бюджету витрачання коштів з
бюджету щодо підтримки збройних сил щодо
підтримки бізнесу ну скажемо так що все
це перетворилося в плідну роботу в
робочих групах в комітеті при при
розгляді поправок якіми оці проекти
закони уже надходили і входили в той чи
інший закон на жаль мені також це не
подобається і я думаю що наші окремі
закони мали бути прийняті і схвалені
Верховною Радою але так склалося і про
це говорили колеги тому Якщо говорити
про пріоритетні напрямки я би розпочала
з того що ми
починали захист в цьому році от робота
полягала лево частина в захисті
можливостей роботи волонтерів меценатів
і юридичних осіб для підтримки збройних
сил абсолютно очевидно було не була
відсутня така системна робота в уряді
яка би давала надію і розуміння всім хто
опікується допомогою як далі діяти це і
по сплаті митних платежів при ввезенні
окремих товарів для збройних сил Це що і
стосується окремих переліків які не
встановлювалися урядом протягом 16
місяців широкомасштабної війни переліку
товарів які могли ввозити юридичні особи
за власний кошт все це Нам вдалось
врегулювати поправками До речі цей
перелік Взагалі відмінений І тепер
юридичні особи можуть надавати і не
сплачувати податки з допомоги яку
надають збройним силам України я Не
перестаю говорити про те що цей рік був
складний ще і в тому що після 22-го року
коли було прийнято ряд ліберальних змін
було прийнято рішення що вони будуть
існувати не до закінчення воєнного стану
а їх терміново Треба відміняти бо нібито
вже здалось владі що бізнес почав
відновлюватися і вже може платити
податки як на довоєнному рівні і
повернутись на цю систему
адміністрування і тут дуже важливо
навіть коли по повертали акцизний
податок на пальне саме за нашої
ініціативи вдалося провести норму щодо
пального для збройних сил щоб це пальне
дизельне пальне не оподатковувалося
акцизом і всі такі ініціативи Вони
настільки важливі і нібито ну знаєте
такі робочі що переважна більшість
громадян навіть не знає що це робота нас
наша робота в комітетах і наш
професійний підхід до всіх
ініціатив ну які були Протягом цього
року нам дуже багато вдавалося зупиняти
норм які Ну просто от відразу шкодять
економіці і бізнесу але їх намагаються
протягнути Я рада що нам все ж таки
вдалось врегулювати питання І можливо і
Далі будемо працювати наприклад щодо
питання повернення документальних
планових перевірок саме працюючи над цим
питанням чи може зараз бізнес витримати
тиск правоохоронців ні звісно не може чи
може зараз бізнес бути на такому ж рівні
як в довоєнний період да звісно не може
бути той хто вважає що це так - Це
абсолютно хибна думка тому ми все робили
для того щоби для і малого і середнього
бізнесу і великого який залишився
працювати не так багато його в Україні
все ж такі умови були стерпні і це наш
було важливе завдання все ж таки
Оскільки ми знаємо відчуваємо всі ті
пропозиції які шкодять економіці ми мали
їх зупиняти і активно боротися проти
цього А скільки наших було ініціатив по
внесенню змін до державного бюджету
України Це просто титанська робота
яка яку ми проводили і в рамках комітету
який і не збирався дослухатися до нас
але ми підняли великий Пласт питань
проте те що саме ми підняли питання що
не пропорційно або
ж Визнач за якимось іншим принципом
підійшли до збільшення видатків на право
на деякі правоохоронні органи саме ті
правоохоронні органи які посилювали тиск
на бізнес ми давали поправки щоби не
робити збільшення таких видатків ми
говорили про те що велика Купа грошей
заплановано ви витрачання їх заплановане
нераціональне з цими видатками можна
потерпіти до закінчення війни А всі ці
гроші давайте спільно спрямуємо прямо на
спеціальні програми які ми виписували в
своїх пропозиціях наприклад 40 млн
резерву з який ми створили за рахунок
зменшення
видатків можна було спрямувати на
закупівлю військової техніки і ми таку
окрему програму пропонували якщо ви ба
бачите всі слайди тут представлено
кропітка робота і по
захисту малого бізнесу який наприклад
уже з 1 січня 2022 року перейшов на
застосування касових апаратів
реєстраторів розрахункових операції якщо
їх правильно назвати і вони вже з 1
січня 22го року попадали під накладення
штрафів якщо вони не використовували це
наша була робота з тим що ми владнали
всі питання і до 1 липня
2023 року ми звільнили їх від цієї
відповідальності і купа інших питань для
самих дріб для самого дрібного бізнесу
для середнього і для великого було
проведено завдяки нашим зусиллям тому
насправді зараз головне не дати
розрушити ту
маленьку відно те маленьке відновлення і
стабільність яка нібито десь жевріє
всередині країни я не Ми не можемо
дозволити щоб громадяни продовжували
виїжджати щоби бізнес релакувався не на
Західну Україну чи більш безпечні місця
а виключно за межі України тому вся наша
робота весь цей рік була спрямована саме
на підтримку України для того щоби ми
Тут жили працювали сплачували податки і
робили бюджет спроможним забезпечити
хоча би
найнеобхіднішим
Дякую колиги вже говорили що основні
принципи якими Ми продовжуємо керуватися
вони прості це армія мова Віра ЄС і НАТО
ми насправді недооцінюємо тієї
величезної роботи яка була зроблена і
українським президентом і українським
парламентом в період між 14- і 19 роками
наше завдання ці наші досягнення
зберегти воно непросте і дуже
відповідальне тому що зараз коли ми
говоримо і даємо цей брифінг в умовах
повномасштабногото торгнення
відповідальність кожного з нас насправді
не просто перед майбутнім а перед тим
щоб це майбутнє було саме для цього наша
фракція європейська Солідарність наша
партія робить все для того щоб об'єднати
суспільство навколо вирішення нагальних
питань коли говорити про гуманітарні
питання ми робили все для того щоб
продовжити сильне створення Української
церкви і заборону діяльності російської
церкви в Україні після отримання томосу
після побудови сильної української
незалежної церкви на жаль російська
церква продовжила свою згубну діяльність
в Україні Ми бачили заі звітів служби
безпеки України інших слідчих органів як
московські попи
продовжують знищувати нашу
самоідентифікацію яким чином вони
займаються колаборантською діяльністю
яким чином вони займаються зрадницькою
діяльністю повідомляючи координати
ворожій армії тих чи інших українських
об'єктів ми бачимо який згубний вплив
вони далі мають на українське
суспільство тому нашою відповідальністю
було зробити все щоб заборонити
діяльність російської церкви в Україні
жод ждним чином ми не претендували і не
претендуємо на обмеження свободи совісті
навпаки ми її захищаємо будь-яка церква
в Україні незалежно в дві розповідання
якщо вона є незалежною від Москви має
право функціонувати працювати в Україні
але якщо це є філія російської церкви на
очільника якої гундяєва накладено
санкції не лише в Україні в Україні ще й
підозру йому вручено а й в багатьох
інших європейських країнах очевидно така
церква не повинна наносити шкоду нашому
суспільству нашій армії і нашим
громадянам тому ми подали закон 8221
який чітко забезпечував би таку заборону
на жаль Парламентська більшість
відмовилася вносити його в зал було
внесено в зал Урядовий законопроєкт який
насправді імітував діяльність заборони
російської церкви порушуючи в тому числі
деякі європейські норми і не будучи
ефективним всередині України попри те ми
підтримали цей закон бо вітаємо кожен
рух до того щоб обмежити діяльність
церкви і розуміємо що маємо докластися
до того щоб кожен закон навіть такий
неефективний нарешті запрацював і
українська церква розвивалася і
російська церква не мала впливу на наші
душі і не зраджувала тут основні
принципи на яких будується наша держава
Тому зараз в нашому комітеті з питань
гуманітарної політики представники
європейської солідарності спільно з
іншими депутатами нашої фракції працюють
напрацювали цілу низку поправок до
урядового законопроєкту маємо надію що
ці поправки буде підтримано в комітеті і
буде підтримано залом хоча Попереду ще
велика і складна боротьба атаки на нашу
мову і на нашу культуру тривають завжди
і під різним так би мовити соусом всі ми
пам'ятаємо коли на виконання рішень
венеційської комісії і рекомендацій щодо
нашого кандидатства у Європейському
Союзі ми прийняли закон про захист
національних меншин ситуація з захистом
національних меншин в Україні дійсно є
чудовою прекрасною національні меншини в
Україні почувають себе негірше ніж
українці ніж будь-яка Інша нація нашої
багатонаціональної країни попри те під
впливом деяких членів Європейського
Союзу зокрема Угорщини намагалися внести
серйозні зміни в цей законопроєкт а
деякі Українські політики намагалися
перекриваючись цим законопроєктом
фактично скасувати наші надбання які ми
маємо після прийняття закону про
забезпечення функціонування української
мови як державної депутати нашої фракції
разом з представниками інших фракцій
доклалися до роботи над цим
законопроектом ми спільно зробили такий
законопроект підкреслюю за ініціативи
саме депутатів нашої фракції який
захистив українську мову захистив всі
наші досягнення і був прийнятий нашими
європейськими партнерами як такий що
гарантує поступ і ще раз засвідчує про
те що права національних меншин в нашій
країні повністю захищені дуже багато
атак на українську мову тривають тоді
коли здається ми їх навіть можемо не
помітити було подано закон про вивчення
англійською мови очевидно всі ми
підтримуємо вивчення англійської мови
оскільки англійська мова є робочою у
багатьох європейських країнах в
Євросоюзі відкри відкриває нові простори
для нашої науки для нашої освіти для
нашого розвитку з нашими стратегічними
партнерами Але разом з тим в цьому
законопроєкті були норми які повністю
забороняли українську мову в кінотеатрах
завдяки представникам європейської
солідарності ці норми були виключені Ми
продовжуємо працювати над проектом про
розвиток англійської мови з метою того
щоб цей проект був ефективним і щоб
жодні антиукраїнські новації туди знову
не потрапили ми прийняли цілу низку
проектів які захищають українське
книговидавництво і обмежують ввіз
літератури з країни агресора і
літератури російською мовою ви Якщо
зайдете в українські книгарні зараз то
побачите величезну кількість книжок які
продаються парадокс але зараз під час
повномасштабного вторгнення українська
книговидавнича галузь відчуває цілий
Ренесанс відбулося це завдяки ініціативі
європейської солідарності і наших колег
які спільно з іншими колегами подавали
законопроєкти для захисту книгови
видавництва е є багато незавершених
речей дуже добре що депутати ЄС разом з
депутатами інших фракцій подали
законопроект Про
ее деколонізацію в топоніміці цей проект
було прийнято Він працює але наш
законопроект Про гуманітарну
деколонізацію який регулює заборону
діяльності всіх колонізаторських
ініціатив в медіа на телебаченні в
радіомовленні в освіті заблокований
Верховною Радою ми і зараз бачимо
приклади коли представники різноманітних
гумористичних груп так би мовити на
загальнонаціональних каналах в так
званому Марафоні е намагаються знущатися
з українською мови принижувати е
українських переселенців принижувати
мешканців сходу і півдня наша фракція
виступає категорично проти цього і
законодавчо і далі буде Робити все щоб
припинити ці потуги бо для нас так само
важливою є і захист свободи слова Ми
пам'ятаємо як працював парламент раніше
журналістів на балконах відкритий
парламент пряма трансляція всього цього
зараз немає ви не можете зараз бачити як
твориться Законодавство це дозволяє
правлячій більшості фактично знищувати
парламентаризм в Україні робити все для
того щоб за спиною наших громадян
приймати закони які потім не працюють в
умовах повномасштабного вторнення - це
злочин тому наша фракція послідовно
виступає за те щоб були повністю
відновлені трансляції Верховної Ради
України Щоб українські журналісти мали
доступ в приміщення українського
парламенту могли поспілкувати
з обранцями людей яких люди делегували
представляти їхні інтереси могли
контролювати роботу і кожного з нас і
всіх депутатів Верховної Ради України
так само ми обстоюємо свободу слова коли
говоримо про те що всі українські
телеканали мають бути в ефірі Ніхто не
вправі незаконно вимикати телеканали з
метою політичної цензури Ніхто не вправі
фінансувати з бюджету так званий
телемарафон який і є втіленням
політичної цензури в Україні очевидно ми
підтримуємо воєнні обмеження очевидно ми
маємо бути обережними допомагати армії і
навпаки допомагати суспільству боротися
з тими хто викладає військові секрети чи
розповідає про ті речі які армія
забороняє але навіть воюючи ми є
демократією нас підтримують наші західні
союзники тому що ми є демократична
країна ми є демократією яку хочуть
знищити авторитарні країни то давайте
бути демократією наша фракція і наша
партія яка декларує що членство в ЄС і в
НАТО є нашими пріоритетами так само
декларує що демократичні принципи є
нашими пріоритетами тому і надалі будемо
робити все для захисту української мови
української культури нашої віри для
підтримки армії для всіх тих цінностей
які об'єднують Європейський союз і НАТО
які мають бути імплементовані і в наше
політичне і суспільне
життя Дякую Шановні колеги ви знаєте
надзвичайно велика відповідальність і
честь для нас з Артуром герасимовим бути
співголовами найбільш професійної
фракції Верховної Ради України нагадаю
що європейська Солідарність наліч лише
27 депутатів і щиро хочу подякувати
своїм колегам зараз Івані климпушснсадзе
яка безумовно є найкращим експертом в
сфері євроатлантичної інтеграції Ніні
южаніні Навіть наші опоненти визнають її
найсильнішу експертні в сфері економіки
Миколі княжицькому який безумовно є
найкращим разом з іншими нашими колегами
експертам в сфері культури гуманітарної
політики свободи слова ростиславу
павленку який не просто представляє на
нашу фракцію в комітеті з питань освіти
А і Є нашим головним аналітиком на ньому
Вся робота по аналізу законопроектів які
надходять до Верховної Ради він бідний
читає оце графоманства імені мазурашу Ну
і готує наші професійні законопроекти і
звичайно Ми дякуємо всім іншим нашим
колегам які докладають кожен свої
зусилля дуже великі в інших сферах це і
самоврядування це і сфера медицини це і
звичайно міжнародна політика це і нац
безпека і оборони і зараз Ірина фріс і
Андрій Парубій знаходяться на тому
комітеті з нацбезпеки На жаль там і досі
знаходиться і Мар'яна яку давно потрібно
вилучити з комітету нацбезпеки і
дискутують цей важливий законопроект про
мобілізацію а власне Я вважаю що це дуже
правильна презентація наших здобутків
нашої роботи і ми Закликаємо всі інші
фракції неухильно дотримуватись
законодавства закону про статус
народного депутата звітувати і особисто
і фракціями І власне це дуже важливо для
наших виборців і наших партійців я
нагадаю що під час воєнного стану більше
2 потися представників європейської
солідарності це члени нашої партії це
депутати різних рівнів стали до лав
збройних сил України і інших сил оборони
країни На жаль
74 наших колеги наших партійці загинули
на жаль 4 три дитини членів родин наших
партійців наших колег депутатів різних
рівнів втратили батька на війні і
очевидно що ці страшні втрати для нашої
команди піднімають високопланку для того
як ми маємо працювати в парламенті по
чутливим для країни темам А ми були тією
політичною силою яка перша прийняла
рішення що під час повномасштабного
вторгнення бюджетні кошти які дуть на
фінансування партій мають бути спрямо
вані саме на підтримку Збройних Сил
України і на ці цілі ми перерахували 54
мльни аби вони пішли саме на закупівлю
Дронів тепловізорів всього що так
сьогодні є в дефіциті в Збройних силах
України а ще більше 28 Мілн 28
300 000 грн пішли на закупівлю машини
DAF це величезні автівки які сьогодні в
користуються повагою дефіцитом на лінії
фронту і це дуже важливо і очевидно ко
Коли наша політична сила надає допомогу
збройним силам Ми ніколи не ділимо це за
партійними прапорами тому що В окопах
всі солдати воюють під одним українським
прапором і це і є єдність насправді
кожен з наших партійців кожен з наших
депутатів 27ми є волонтером є
благодійником звичайно тут найвищу
планку тримає наш лідер Петро Порошенко
фонд якого більше 4ох мльярдів гривень
за ці два роки спрямував на допомогу
збройних сил України Я дуже пишаюся всі
ми дуже пишаємося нашими регіонами адже
там створено
284 волонтерські хаби представниками
партії депутатами різних рівнів і 73 з
них працюють в екстремальних умовах в
наших партійних офісах в тому числі в
Дніпрі де тричі вже російськими атаками
е були е нанесені е збитки і пошкодження
нашому офісу в тому числі в Харкові в
тому числі в Херсоні от звідки Ми
нещодавно повернулися і очевидно що ця
робота також є важливою
складовою внеску нашої політичної сили в
майбутню перемогу я дякую колегам які
дуже детально розповіли про
законодавство яке ми відстоюємо в
контексті допомоги і захисту армії і
саме завдяки зусиллям нашої команди і
Олексія Гончаренка і інших колег Нам
вдалося дотиснути що збільшили відпустки
представникам збройних сил України до 30
діб а не 10ти повернули виплати певним
категоріям І от нам тільки поінформували
Що наприклад хоча цей закон було
прийнято в червні 23го року наприклад
інструкторам лише зараз виплатили ці
виплати Це ненормально і тому правильно
зауважують колеги ми маємо повернути
годину запитань до уряду щоби уряд був
під контрольний парламенту А шмигаля за
два роки ми в парламенті бачили аж один
раз Це не наша історія і ми бачимо що з
цим непрофесійним урядом друзі біда І
тут потрібно не просто якісь косметичні
зміни вносити там на рівні Я не знаю
міністра ветеранів а просто формувати
уже не уряд навіть національної єдності
а уряд національного порятунку де буде
зрозуміла економічна програма
гуманітарна програма програма руху до ЄС
і НАТО з послідовними планами не в
останню хвилину написаними а створеними
завчасна і звичайно серйозною
аналітичною роботою для нас дуже
важливим колеги є це дійсно те про що
заявила Ніна Петрівна це скасування ПДВ
для
імпорту товарів критичного просто
призначення таких як дрони і
внутрішнього виробництва і все-таки ми
наполягаємо на тому аби уряд представив
економічну програму яка допоможе фронту
Ну і на останок наша позиція по
мобілізації для команди 25 стисяч членів
якої сьогодні на фронті а наприклад
серед них є Степан Барна в десятці вже
два роки цей легендарний підро зділ
знаходиться під бахмутом або наші
партійці під авдіївкою ми усвідомлюємо
як цим бригадам потрібно поповнення
відновлення ротація демобілізація тому
що бути два роки під бахмутом чи під
авдіївкою і на десь блокпосту там чи в
військоматі в Києві це різні історії
тому ми вважаємо що мобілізація потрібна
і більше того Наша команда вісім разів
голосували і за мобілізацію і за
продовження воєнного стану за ті закони
які президент Зеленський як верховний
головнокомандувач вносив до сесійної
зали Ми наполягаємо на тому що саме
верховний головнокомандувач має подати
законопроект про посилення і
структуризацію мобілізації як представ
як очільник насправді цієї цього
безпекового напрямку держави згідно
своїх конституційних обов'язків і
повноважень дуже важливо аби там були і
ми наполягаємо на цьому передбачені
умови для демобілізації наприклад
онкохворих в Збройних Силах чи тих людей
які мають важкі поранення там всі оці от
зараз незаконні абсолютно дії уряду
шмигаля спікера стефанчука який за за
два роки війни жодного разу не поїхав
підрозділи хай поїде Хай поспілкується
може він запитає де ж ці Дрони на 42
млрд які вони закупили начебто може він
поспілкується як люди ставляться там
військові до марафону і чи треба
сьогодні 2 млрд на марафон чи їх
потрібно направити на фінансування
однієї з бригад але сенс В тому що всі
неконституційні іти оці корупційні
обмеження вони не можуть існувати в
законі Про мобілізацію хочете вносити
якісь ініціативи кладіть їх в основу
законопроекту будемо дискутувати в залі
рухатися по ним але ніякими підзаконними
актами це не можна посилювати всупереч
закону І такою буде наша позиція Ми
чекаємо все-таки законопроектне імені
колективной безуглей а поданий від
президента Зеленського і очевидно що
наша ключова зада дача як сказали колеги
на 24-й рік - це збереження єдності
здорового глузду це дуже важливо
сьогодні для країни віри в інституції і
збереження інституції тому що бачимо
спроби сьогодні зруйнувати інституції
починаючи від уряду який став філією
офісу президенту і закінчуючи
парламентом І власне для цього нам
потрібно кілька речей це безумовно
прозора робота парламенту підзвітна
робота парламенту і тут ми не тільки
говори а й демонструємо це власним
прикладом Закликаємо інших колег з усіх
фракцій так само звітувати про свою
роботу з радістю Я думаю це послухають і
виборці і і самі Ми всі з радістю
послухаємо хто як працював Тому що іноді
приходиш до зали а там людей мало і або
багато і не дуже зрозуміло що
відбувається і ще раз хочемо від всього
серця подякувати в першу чергу збройним
силам України які дають можливість
українському парламенту працювати в
22-му і 23 роках і в 24-му який настав
українцям які дивують своєю стійкістю
патріотизмом і великим внеском в нашу
майбутню перемогу Дякуємо нашим виборцям
які нас підтримують і попри Ну там тиск
який ми відчуваємо щоденно від влади ми
знаємо що в нас такий надійний тил який
додає нам сил Ми дякуємо членам нашої
команди і в першу чергу 25ся партійців і
партійок тому що більше 50 жінок
партійок сьогодні в лавах Збройних Сил
України Ви наші найкращі представники Ну
і звичайно ми з Артуром і з Петром
олексійовичем Дякуємо 27 членам нашої
фракції цієї найсильнішої
найпрофесійнішої найкращої команди в
Верховній Раді України яка дуже гідно
тримає планку що таке є український
парламентар дякуємо